"Game of Thrones" is not exactly known for its
morally upstanding characters. This approach
means that terms like "good" and "evil" mean very
little in the war-torn fantasy world of Westeros.
Characters who seem honorable and righteous
also make horrific choices and the dastardly,
so-called villains occasionally
perform acts of kindness and honor.
With that in mind, Margaery Tyrell, played by
Natalie Dormer, has a lot in common with her
peers on the show. While always hungry for power,
like most characters on "Game of Thrones," she
does possess kindness and understanding that is
quite uncommon among other royalty in Westeros.
Still, no one is incapable of making terrible,
inexcusable choices, and Margaery is no different.
“I am the Queen.”
In fact, there's one particular story arc
of hers that some would argue simply goes
way too far, even in this world of
murder, betrayal, and oppression.
Margaery Tyrell is originally supposed to
marry the cruel and brutal Joffrey Baratheon,
played by Jack Gleeson. However, upon his
assassination, she marries Tommen Baratheon,
played by Dean-Charles Chapman instead. Tommen is
far kinder than his brother but more susceptible
to manipulation because of his young age and
naivety. Margaery uses this to her advantage
and emotionally manipulates the young king
into doing everything she wants. It's a
truly uncomfortable relationship, and every scene
between the two characters is difficult to watch.
Eventually, after Margaery is killed by Tommen's
mother, Cersei, Tommen dies by suicide by jumping
from a tower. While it's clear that his
mother, with her thirst for power above all
else, shares responsibility for this, the
deeply problematic relationship between
Margaery and Tommen is at fault too. The
fact that it ends so tragically is not only
a testament to how realistic "Game of Thrones"
can be at times. It’s also another indicator
of just how grim and unrelenting the show is
when it comes to killing off its characters.
So was it worth it for Margaery? The young
woman successfully becomes Queen of the Seven
Kingdoms through her marriage to Joffrey, and then
Tommen, but it's quite a short reign. She easily
gains control of Tommen, who falls in love with
her, but she can't beat Cersei's manipulations,
which lead the Faith Militant to arrest
her brother Loras and then her. Tommen,
without enough knowledge about the world
of politics and how to use his power,
is unable to save his wife or
handle the emotional aftermath.
Tommen's history of being coddled by his
mother and abused by his older brother
shapes him into the innocent and ill-prepared king
he becomes. Likewise, Margaery's manipulative ways
are definitely created by those who raised her. In
her case, the most influential person in her life
is arguably Olenna Tyrell, her grandmother and
the matriarch of the Tyrell line. We all know how
cunning the old woman is, successfully murdering
Joffrey at his own wedding and framing Tyrion
in order to get Margaery on the throne. This in
turn leads to her marriage to Tommen. You could
even argue that Olenna is to blame for Margaery's
death, although this is undoubtedly unintentional.
Olenna truly loves her granddaughter
and would do anything to protect her.
Margaery has ambitious dreams born from Olenna's
guidance, and she knows how to manipulate people,
especially men, in order to get what she
wants. She's taught that power and control
is the main goal in life — no matter the
cost — which Olenna continuously encourages.
While Margaery appears to actually be a good
person and care for Tommen, she is too blinded by
the influences of her family and the psychological
warfare going on in King's Landing. Margaery tries
to manipulate Tommen while still keeping him safe.
However, in the end her own goals remain the top
priority and Margaery uses Tommen as a pawn,
leading him down the path to his horrific fate.
Compared to other characters in
"Game of Thrones," especially Cersei,
Margaery seems like a saint. But is
she just as bad as the rest of them
for the death her manipulations
cause, or is she also a victim?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.